في هذه الاثناء قالت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
ان الرئيس فولدومرسيلنسكي زار مدينه
باخموت على خط الجبهه في شرق اوكرانيا
في تصريح له ان المعارك التي تشهدها
تكسر الجيش الروسي ومن وصفهم بالمرتزقه
الذين جندتهم روسيا ليحلوا محل قوتها التي
تضررت الحرب على بلاده واضاف ان روسيا
فقدت خلال الحرب لا يقرب من 99 الفا من
جنودها متواعده موسكو بمدينه
كل شويه
الان هي ان يكون الدعم العالمي لاوكرانيا
في العام المقبل على اعلى مستوى لا تزال
بخمود المكان الاكثر سخونه على خط
المواجهه باكمله والمعارك تشجيع على خط
بطوله 200300 كيلو متر منذ ما يويار
والاحتلال ويحاول دخول محمود
اجابه على هذا السؤال ولن تكون لديهم
اجابه انهم يخشون الاعتراف بالواقع